morning ian yes as you know we were due
to hold a leadership debate between
those remaining in the contest tomorrow
night but sky news can confirm that the
debate has been cancelled and that's
because two of the three candidates
currently leading in the mp's ballots
that's rishi sunak and liz trust have
confirmed to sky news that they don't
wish to take part in that debate and i
think the context to this ian is that
the candidates themselves and indeed the
tory party centrally have been concerned
that the
blue one blue attacks during this debate
the attacks by the candidates on each
other and on aspects of the government's
record have not reflected particularly
well on the tory party's reputation and
the obvious deep divisions between them
on economic policy and many other issues
so they're seeking to avoid having more
open hostility we can give you a quote
from the source in the sunac team saying
if we're fortunate enough to progress in
the contest we're looking forward to
taking part in further debates later in
the contest but we understand that liz
truster's team will not be taking part
in any debates
all right tamara thanks for that